is it possible to return to a place
where there is friendly competition
between nations that ultimately
um
unites and inspires the peoples of these
different worlds these very different
worlds that have especially recently uh
come to conflict over the over the war
in Ukraine the tension builds uh the war
the conflict the suffering is actually
creating more and more division creating
more and more hate I think as we've
talked about I think science and
engineering and especially the most epic
version of engineering which is a rocket
train space travel unites people the
United people even in a time of tension
conflict and War so do you have a hope
that we can return to that place
I think historically spaceflight has
been one of the most bonding things you
know we look at we have countless
examples of you know Cold War enemies
coming together and working together
lending a hand
um Apollo 13 for example of course you
know there is the potential that who
knew where it was going to re-enter
since it was not in the planned
trajectory at all for re-entry and the
Soviet Union said hey wherever you know
wherever they land like we'll help you
guys out basically you know that was a
pretty big thing at the time obviously
um we also in 1975 saw the Apollo soyuz
Mission which was an Apollo spacecraft
docking with soyuz spacecraft first time
there's International collaboration and
again 1975 still very admits the Cold
War
yet we have this collaboration
um that I don't know what else could
have done that you know I mean and think
about what it actually takes to do that
you have to come up with a a docking
module that is you you know like that
takes the two different air environments
and the two different docking systems
and talk to the engineers and Mission
planners and figure out you know train
together the the cosmonauts and the
astronauts trained together and got to
know each other they were crossing
boundaries and borders and coming
together for this Mission and even if it
was totally a Fluff piece like even if
it was totally this like you know
cynical you know just
trying to make a pretty face for
everybody for the for the cameras or
something obviously it still had an
impact yeah it's a symbolic impact but
there's also the Practical impact I mean
a lot of people have to work together
yes and that and that has a ripple
effect on the culture on the different
engineers
uh yeah 100 and even just the the
astronauts and the cosmonauts involved
like think about what what probably went
through their heads during this process
of like going from oh my God I'm gonna
have to work with them to getting to
know them and then sharing meals in
space like that's a crazy transformation
of of timelines and I would love to I I
do think that spaceflight has the the
ability to to bond us and unite us
because it is
ultimately you know this little tiny
little planet we're floating around on
you know it's the only it is the
boundary that we all share you know you
only can you it only takes you getting
off this planet to realize oh my God
we're all neighbors we're all living in
the same house together and
I I do think ultimately you know as we
continue to uh expand our Horizons and
expand our exploration that it has the
potential to to unite us more than than
it has the potential to divide us so one
of the potential conflicts of the 21st
century that I think everyone wants to
avoid both in the cyberspace and in the
hot War space Cold War Hot War all kinds
of War all kinds of economic conflict as
with between the United States and China
so China is
going full steam ahead in developing a
space program doing a lot of incredible
work like you mentioned uh 64 launches
in 2022 with two failures
but you know Moving Straight Ahead
um
we had a lot of startups like a lot of
the launches were from brand new
companies so to have two failures out of
64. I mean that's still if you look at
operational launches it was flawless
do you see a pathway
where there's again in that same way
collaboration
or a friendly competition between all
the different companies and nations of
the United States and China in the in
the next as we push towards the moon uh
Mars and Beyond I held a dumb hope that
China would actually be allowed to sign
onto the Artemis Accord to be able to
take part in this next step towards the
moon and just imagine if like if they
provided a you know a propulsion module
or a Lander or something and we actually
came together to land on the Moon
instead of having another space race you
know it's like it would have been so
cool and
yeah I still am hopeful that
similar to to back in the cold war that
we might have something like that
someday where we actually are
collaborating and it feels like
sometimes we're really close to that and
then other times it feels like we're
really far from that and it just sucks
because I know and you know I try really
hard on my channel to to always separate
and celebrate the work being done you
know because at the end of the day
there's someone that's just going home
to their family clocking an hour is
working really hard on on pushing their
program and and doing engineering work
you know and it's
uh we don't get to choose where we're
born and what we're born into
um so I really like to avoid
you know the the political aspects of
things and the geopolitical aspects and
just appreciate the science and the the
science we're seeing and the the
progress that China's doing in the last
10 years is is very akin to the you know
early space flight programs and and with
the runway of like just going keeping on
going like I see no reason for them to
be slowing down so it's it's definitely
something to watch and and be interested
in and who knows I mean there really
genuinely might be a race to the moon
again and there really genuinely might
be a race to Mars
hey the part of me is excited about that
because a race is is pretty cool yeah uh
but
hopefully it's friendly competition and
some collaboration it is true that uh
maybe I'm being a bit cynical but
Nations sometimes governments and
leaders of those governments sometimes
ruin things like you don't often have
I think statistically speaking it's
harder to have a leader of a nation that
looks beyond the political the
particular political bickering of that
nation and you have like a JFK type
character that really steps up and
inspires I think statistically speaking
it's better to have somebody like Elon
who's the leader of a company a
commercial effort that is able to look
beyond the borders of Nations and uh
certainly inspiring Educators like
yourself uh to look beyond the borders
of those Nations and the geopolitical
conflicts and so on to uh to inspire the
to inspire people I think that's just
made so much easier like you can have
more reach
uh Tim Tim Dodd can have more reach than
NASA right like in terms of inspiring
the world and that's fascinating like
that that gives power to the individuals
let's see past the the the silly
short-term geopolitical conflicts yeah
that's the hope at least